it seems also that the u.s. championship
is getting tougher by the year I
remember when I first played there in
2015
Fabiana wasn't here yet in the rating
average was much much lower even in the
previous year obviously the field was
super strong after you know Wesley and
Fabiano were also playing but there
still may be one or two players who are
a little bit lower
didn't quite belong you know - maybe
this this very strong tournament I mean
this wasn't a excellent experience for
all of them but they we knew before they
turn out that these guys cannot win well
now I feel like everyone is just all
super close so yeah there's not going to
be any easy games and it's just a really
strong tournament this is for sure the
strongest tournament them and also the
average level is probably the strongest
ever now it's getting tougher every year
with emergent balance amongst the
juniors you have a couple interesting
players for example you have Jeffrey
who's played a couple of times now is
he's almost a veteran in a sense and
then you have a wonderland this is first
time playing the US Championship ever
after having won the US Junior
Championship more and more up-and-coming
young American players as well as more
players switching over to the US and
moving here both of which make the
competition much tougher I can judge it
by the fact how hard it is to be in top
10 in the US now I'm actually number 10
was 26:40 fidei and I remember just a
few years ago even like being just
barely 2600 was enough to be in top 10
and now it's not it was very hard just
to qualify to this tournament I had to
win a very tough tournament with 18
grandmasters in in the tournament it
will be a very interesting experience
for me and just test my strength see how
I can do here well anything can happen
in one tournament so I'm hopeful I know
those guys are monsters but I'll try to
do my best
[Music]